makes them feel ugly and unworthy
there's too many for some reason you
guys okay
how many guys
you guys are all you're pretty girls you
have your pick of the litter like you
shut up stop I'm saying like you have
your pick of the litter you guys at 21
22 could pick a nice guy that you could
get married to and so it's it's on you
if you're 50 if you're 30 single and
childless you're there bad at picking
men it's like that's on you
why can't we just take accountability
for our decisions
now you say it takes two to tango but
let's keep it 100.
he's the person that's opening their
legs is it the guy or is it the girl so
okay let me tell you something my friend
I get into a relationship with
you and then one day you grow into
something because at the end of the day
people grow and they change constantly
change is constant for sure and two
years down the line you actually feel
different because it's just life okay
somebody that you connect with more and
you don't want to be with me anymore and
you leave me I've tried my best and I
want to be with you but actually I'm not
your soul mate you found your soulmate
and you left me okay you're saying how
is that my fault you're saying make you
feel love whatever [__] but let's
keep it real you girls like the bad boys
and these boys don't even make
not everyone but modern females strictly
do and they not strictly either yes they
do because if they do they wouldn't like
around the 19 to 25 they would like give
more attention to the nice guys you guys
don't think that there's a group of
women that enjoy chasing after the
Futures and the Drakes of the world okay
that's the best thing is that as a group
of women it's not women in general when
we say modern women that is who we're
talking about the the Sierras of the
world okay how many people are you
Sierra how many you how many people use
Sierra as an example of a single mother
where it turned out okay
for every for every one Sierra there's a
hundred girls that that doesn't happen
foreign
I think somebody you know how you get
the whole Beyonce independent woman I
don't basically I think everything that
you would put in the category of a
modern woman but not just looking for
the bad boy not just this I think with
more depth to her do you know what do
you mean more depth I think the Modern
Woman you know who's a good example of a
modern woman now I think Rihanna is a
good example somebody that hustled and
found her love and she settled down on
that love and her and her man are doing
projects together they're working
together now they have a baby and they
look happy
it's richer than him let me tell you
something though he's a bad boy he has a
crowd here the stairs and he's the 10
percent Ally okay but that's because
she's the one percent would you like
would you like but so you used you used
Rihanna right but for every girl that
tries to be Rihanna and tries to lock
down that guy there's a million that
don't and so there's a million
unsuccessful Rihanna
and so she she she's in the top what 10
of Beauty in her prime you know she's
over 30 now she'll sleep let's drop her
down a point but like like in in general
to Rihanna's level ASAP Rocky is here
actually and that's what it is because
Rihanna is the superstar Rihanna is but
men don't care about that I know but I'm
just saying an example of a beautiful
powerful rich woman who actually went
for somebody that she fell in love with
and for her he's the right guy whether
he's rich or not
again she doesn't really matter
she's lucky she's that beautiful because
outside of that she doesn't generally
have what men want Purity and youth she
was known for giving like like there was
some national headline of her giving
some dude an STD okay
so and and so she's not pure and then
she's old she's she's like 32 or
something okay measured on success and
women are measured on age [__] yeah
and so that's it wow it's not it's not
fun I'm not I don't like it's not fun
that's why Linda's winning right now but
can I just say something at the end of
the day now we can judge and say all of
this stuff but then not at the end of
the day is if she's got kids with this
guy they probably will get married if
they haven't already got married in
secret they can actually live happily
ever after because what it and I don't
know what the ins and out of their
relationships are but judging for more I
can see and giving the past that she's
had in the man that she has found he's
somebody that respects her clearly
somebody that they that she trusts and
he trusts because they're collaborating
a lot and I'm sure she would not have a
baby
and again
that was rumors and so all I'm trying to
say is that do you really think ASAP
Rocky is faithful like did you know you
never know you never know not every
single rapper
ASAP rookie isn't faithful she's
probably still going to be even because
she's the type of man if we look at her
past dating history Chris Brown Drake
all these men what did they all have in
that in common they're always people
with different type of foods maybe the
reason why she's staying with him fully
and having a baby with him it's because
he might be he's the one for her she's
the one
the modern women you gave an example of
is like still doing the same [__] no
right like even the example you guys
gave like that's a perfect example
as a modern woman but I don't think I'm
the kind of modern women no see what
she's talking about is another woman
that acts as substance let's keep it 100
the modern woman that don't have
substance believe they're like the top
prize or like Rihanna and they feel
entitled to certain behaviors
let me tell you something so let me tell
you something like
a staple of the modern woman right they
believe that they are higher than their
level right so I've always said you see
when you take your makeup off and your
lashes off and your nails off and your
wig off and your hair inches out and
then you go to bed that's what you are
that's your level
I feel like I always get this though
yeah hang on hang on hang on
like you're higher than your level
because you put makeup on and weave in
and Nails on no but it's okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait what do you
mean
a lot of modern women tend to think that
because how they look after they're made
up that's their level no my dear because
of the bottom line is when a man goes to
bed with you you've gone back down to
that level and that is what he's seeing
on a daily basis when you're walking
around the house that's what you're
seeing so don't act
like you're a 10 when you're uh
and at carnival and at carnival when I
was asking I went around I said rate
yourself one to ten
ten I'm a ten I'm a 10 I'm a ten bro
you're like a five you're average look
yeah but again
is it not okay to set to be confident
though no no no but it's not okay it's
not okay to lie to yourself but let's
keep it 100 you see the makeup the wick
is off it's all a must it's a must I
personally believe that when girls are
have makeup when you approach them they
have a different personalities if you
approach someone yeah when you're
approaching without makeup they tend to
be more portable more talkable more have
more of a Vibe but when you approach
them when they have makeup they're all
like I'm this [__] I'm this [__] but why
are you hold on my makeup as well when
actually men
makeup is fine but
women will speak they will spend two
hours on their homework do you know what
I'm saying and they will look totally
different we've all seen fishing videos
we've all seen The Tick Tock videos of
women looking a certain way doing her
makeup
right okay so there are a lot of women
out there me Brandon uh what's your name
again bro Fury out we don't need to do
that we are beautiful right but we look
like this all the time right yourself do
you look like now I'm just saying the
truth because a lot of women like don't
think they tell me because of all these
makeup only all these fake things but us
men as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible